to introduce our speaker who's our
summer intern um Isaac's background is
that he grew up in California at Davis
California and then he went to Lewis and
Clark to study math and of his
background was mostly pure math and that
s he went through college got interested
in how he can apply that theory to
real-world practice and then from that
got interested in health care and then
got interested in volatile informatics
and study spent the summer working with
a group of us basically Michelle and
Sarah and Isaac and they've been doing
sort of a clinical work flow modeling
stimulation and then the piece that
Isaac's going to talk about which is
visualizations at the HR time stamps ok
so on so I want if you watch according
to come in here it's lovely so thank you
all for coming I'm Isaac and behind my
wife's doing versity creating
visualization speedrun stents start out
background and motivation for why we're
living at work flow problems and bhi
records the first place and lots of
other Googlers visualizations themselves
and then some data problems that they
made for us next so so I'm just gonna
talk a little about the context of the
problems facing show in 2008 electronic
health records were used by just seventy
percent of positions 12-person with
hospitals States but there was a lot of
basically the information that said that
if you start using when trying to
comprehensive you can manage to
coordinate care patients you can both
improve their health our hands and also
use the costs which is a very attractive
proposition and so in 2009 is part of
the economic stimulus package the HITECH
Act was passed by the federal government
to help incentivize hospitals to you by
investing these early expensive
complicated systems which has been a
very successful endeavor by 2014
seventy-six percent hospitals
electronic health record system so
that's great unfortunately a big change
like that there are some challenges and
they're very particular ones to
productivity so just looking at ohsu in
kc i instituted in ophthalmology
department after topping the epic
healthcare system in 2006 opthamologist
see on average 25 percent pure 24 and it
takes about forty percent more for
additional time for the patient
encounters which is quite a lot at the
same time there's a strong impression
for patients to for providers to see
more patients over time for less per
person and there is a really a lot of
guidance on how to do that effectively
with these new challenges the people
faces so the focus of our research group
is to try and alleviate some of these
productivity problems although actually
not through a solemn health record
problem but rather by trying to address
issues related to scheduling and
resource management yourselves so timely
dress structural problems there so the
idea is to try and come up with
strategies to better manage the
resources of the clinic order to better
schedule appointments so that flows
better but that's not really the sort of
thing that you can test out on actual
clinics so you have to find some other
way to test out Leah's and basically one
way to do that is with discrete event
simulation so you can create models of
your clinics and try and test new ideas
which models and see what you get by
doing that but for a model like that any
of a lot of data to effectively store
where they come from and well electronic
health records keep track of every
person who's logging in and out of them
all the time so the idea is that the
idea is that what you can try to do is
take the times that the provider has
been logged in and logged out of the
system has approximately the time that
they are spending with the fishing
themselves and hopefully that will work
out so when we're talking about modeling
we're going to talk about modeling an
ophthalmology for you today the reasons
for that is that it's a relatively
complex clinic at an ophthalmology
clinic you see some kind of you know
some kind of initial exam with some sort
of insult or staff member a tech or not
orth optus you may have your eyes
dilated so you would actually leave the
exam room for certain amount of time and
then come back we're forcing the
physician so there's a lot of movement
back and forth between patients and
staff and so it's a reasonably
interesting problem and it's still
reasonably generalizable if you go to a
regular physician instead you would see
if nurse and have your weight taken and
your temperature taken and all that sort
of stuff so still applicable to other
places but it's still an interesting
problem to look at so the hope is that
these electronic health record time
stamps that we have will sort of line up
with this idea of the model and we'll be
able to use them as a proxy and using
this data to do savings with so other
members of our group Sarah Michelle not
me did a bunch of works validating the
electronic health record time stamps so
they went in observed actual clinics and
took measurements so what you have here
are the two distributions for exam time
duration for staff and for physicians
the blue is observed the pink is
electronic health records and when we're
running a model what the model is going
to do is it's going to sample from this
distribution and take exam time through
there so what you want is for these
distributions that blue the pink to
overlap as much as possible and the good
news is is they overlap quite a bit so
that says to us that we have models we
have data that's good enough to use for
them and so the next question is what do
you want to test and that was sort of
where I was brought in so I would
brought in to create timelines of these
ophthalmology clinics using tableau for
about a year's worth for about four
different clinicians and try to generate
strategies for reducing the wait time
and there are a lot of different things
that you can do with something like this
but we decided to try and focus on
reducing the amount of time
patients waiting and try to answer of
course the question of what is a bad or
good day and the clinical look like so
that's what we did and this is an
example of one of those timelines that
we came up with so basically each bar
represents a patient appointment and
then you have a couple of different
things to go through so the yellow green
stands for the time the patient is
waiting but they are early there before
their schedule is a time the electric
blue is time when the patient's not
there yet but there was pursued than
they're so tender late gray stands for
time that they're waiting they're not
seeing anybody and it's a miracle point
of time and then the other colors stand
for their interactions with various
staff members and then read or with
their dilating when their eyes are
dilated excuse me um so and that's
pretty cool that this sort of works and
you end up with a reasonably nice
picture of what it looks like it you can
kind of track the provider moving
throughout the day pretty convincing
languages quite exciting and just to
sort of go through further you can click
on all the different little colorful
bars and it will give me some
information about who has logged in how
long that particular bar was a duration
it can do a couple of other things but
that's what we have into it right now
hello and by the way I forgot to mention
these numbers here this is the scheduled
visit day plus with us so just to sort
of zoom in on this one in particular you
know sort of some promising news that
we're initially looking at this day had
this really long provider isn't in time
in the morning that could be sort of
delay exams later on in the day there's
also this sort of triple evaluations
that's happening here that's also
possibly preventing the provider from
seeing a different patient earlier and
so there's the sorts of things that add
up and cascade throughout the day
perhaps and then we also sort of started
to examine good days versus bad days so
this is a much better day than this one
there's a lot of this gray going on and
so you can see some real differences
too and that's reasonably promising um
but basically the more that we looked at
these charts the more that we started to
see that there were actual problems with
the data itself and so we started
investigating that so that's going to
talk about next is problems with data
that we're trying to solve ER have
solved that we found because of these
visualizations that we made so problem
one it has to do for a lot of time
stamps so again we're trying to solve
reducing patient wait time during the
day so one of the things that we need to
know in order to know how long a patient
is waiting is how long they're busy how
long they're with somebody doing
something but what can happen and of
course is that there are multiple things
that are happening at the same time
which show on their timelines is the
sort of overlaps so that we have sort of
a tech and the text starts a dilation
time for the patient but the tank is
still working tech is lightly logged out
and then we have this provider coming in
again while the violation is still
happening and so the problem being that
when you have these overlapping times
you have multiple things going on at the
same time if you try and count all of
these separate bars as time that the
patient's busy you're over counting and
so pretty frequently what happens is if
we're taking the way time to be the
difference between the total point of
time and the times and all of these
times that there with somebody we end up
with negative the patient wait times
which is clearly not happening so we had
to kind of work through how to
straighten on this problem and basically
we came up with an algorithm that does
that so this is sort of an example for
our algorithm and basically the scenario
that we have before slightly exaggerated
where we have a technician who's talking
to the patient and then they start a
dilation process but they're still
talking with the patient doing something
and then patients dilated and then
perhaps the provider shows up early and
you have all of this overlap that's
going on here and you don't really want
that so what our algorithm does it takes
for a particular deployment it takes all
of the interactions that are having
during the appointment in a puts them in
order and it starts comparing them so we
take greeting first and we compare
you're green to red and we slice off all
read that overlaps green and we get this
next term here which is great and then
we move down and take yellow now now too
green and we slice off all of the yellow
boots that were left with green and then
finally we now move on to read and we
take all the yellow that overlaps thread
and slice it off and now we end up with
this total bar here which is the actual
time that the patient is busy seeing
somebody which is the actual number that
were interested in so that was quite
guys so that was the first problem that
we actually managed to solve to question
my name is this yes nation times that's
an HR time span that someone presented
as when they get it or it's my name oh
good question yes so it might have been
a little or a little later but yeah we
take like an average time of like I
wanna take it um why is it necessary to
slice out like the violation in the
middle of if your goal is to give the
actual time the patient is busy why not
to take the earliest starting time and
the latest and just be done with I mean
mysterious is there a reason to well so
essentially what we're trying to
reserves figure out what's overlapping
and then if they're overlapping and we
get rid of it is over lag so it's
possible that there are events that
happened between more play around don't
overlap so in the process so we just
have to make sure that we're finding all
possible overlaps and then if they or
whatever being writable so we can't miss
it so when we do find it over left yes
we are taking essentially the start not
all things over and then are these I'm
people are being charted is that based
on when they log into the workstation in
the room or is it based on yeah so a lot
of the worst issue so then attack and a
provider or log into the work day in the
room at the same time I mean this is a
slightly exaggerated example to be
honest with you but I'm not actually
sure it cannot actually happen I have
definitely so I definitely gone through
and I have seen things in the
visualizations that look like a provider
exam and in the middle of the exam the
text shows up and does something else I
don't know the details of how that works
in perhaps that's a narrative
visualization but it is certain that
something that shows up and so something
we have to deal with not usual and then
this is sort of an issue in general yes
T highly correlated overlaps a violation
and then the prior yeah yeah the things
that some of these workstations we have
been after generic workstations that
aren't necessarily in the roof of a
dieta always even have two people long
as the same time or someone may not log
off is in your finish the room yeah like
that's still working for that patient
yeah okay great so that's over like a
time problem and then then we basically
found another problem other than dead
one so the other problem is that
basically we're missing data so there
are a lot of different timelines where
you have these really amazed acts
between patient interactions with some
staff and basically there were so many
that we just started to get suspicious
that we would probably missing something
just to sort of zoom in here's a
particularly good example where you have
the tech me through the patient who is
like an hour early and then nothing
happens for 40 minutes and then they see
you again and then nothing happens for
another hour and then they see the
provider and we just sort of saw this
over and over getting thought that's
like
and so we're probably missing something
which it turns out that we were so
basically what we were doing so
basically from here what we did is we
went back and looked through the data
again using a different search
originally our search is based around
finding all of the importance for each
provider associated with each provider
but that's going to happen tile I guess
I forgot but when we run the search
again not doing that anymore we pick up
this provider exam which we had before
and then we actually pick up two other
exams that happen and pretty nicely at
least slot into you exactly where we had
those gaps before so it turns out we
were just we were missing these other
exams that happened where patients tend
to go and get a visual field test or
they're said to have their eyes
photographed or something like that
which is not associated with the
provider but it happens still within the
exam itself track of it so yeah so we
sort of went back and found oh there's
all this other day that we're missing so
let's try and hold this data and we did
but that ended up giving us a few other
problems but I guess basically first
before I talk about that you know we
found out basically that our original
model was not really correct that
there's this other thing going on with
the McCune visual field that we have to
take into account and so we need to
adjust our model so doing that and then
we try and pull some new data see what
it looks like and it doesn't look so
nice so the most immediate problem when
we pull this new data this is the exact
same appointment as it was before but
things have changed a little bit somehow
the checkout time is about 10pm the
reason for that is that one of the
appointments that we searched up had a
check-in time but now no checkout time
whatsoever and so we have to put in some
kind of dubbing time what we're trying
to figure out what to do with that
basically one of the things that we're
currently working on is trying to come
up with rules that help us end these
appointments without checkout times
which is a very common
with these other Pacific app but I mean
there's some good news if you sort of
look at all of the different colors and
roles that we're now starting to pick up
we're picking up a photo tag working a
couple of other things so we are picking
up new information but the other problem
is that you'll notice a lot of these
bars really thin and in a lot of cases
all of the new information or picking up
is four times that last for like less
than a minute which still suggest that
we are not really pulling up all of the
day that we're looking for and so that's
an ongoing problem that we're trying to
solve now yes but I don't understand how
do you have a nun time before right okay
so what we had before is an end time for
this appointment in the middle which has
to check out times but we don't have a
checkout time through this appointment
right here and so and this happens like
this is just this particular example but
this happens all the time of variety
reports we don't have a check out of
time and so we still have to put
something in here before it will sort of
show it nicely in the visualization and
we just pick something really really
really long for now and then fix it
later basically yeah yeah and that's
definitely yes actually coming when
blends due to the first time through is
there a reason why is done by provider
or not my patient goes to my patient is
this would have come up earlier just
curious cuz I know previous working
something I like seeing a certain
providers are slower or like you certain
provide at different times a and that's
why it made sense what evidence this
like it's just because he was continuing
in that process and that's why cool
pretty so that's most of what I have to
say today big takeaways visualizations
can help generate strategies and
possible hypotheses for increasing clean
productivity they can also be really
good at finding problems with your data
that you otherwise would not seen and
there are still many problems with using
your shared data to get a full picture
of a patient with it so our ongoing work
we're trying to create rules to define
my encounters ended in a way that will
to be most useful to us and search for
this missing data future work
incorporating this new data once we find
it and generate test strategies so my
presentation knowledge thank all these
people and organizations yeah that's
what I got for you any questions so
you're like [ __ ] all things that
overlap no hey later you want to go and
look at the average valuation time are
those values looks like stock value for
you I'm kidding me separate so when
we're slicing off I just create a new
variable that's just like I think I
called like actual exam time or
something like that and I just some nice
pieces and totally legal on all of the
original data because you're right we
totally want to look at all those things
how often does the last time the end
time of the last activity course on to
basically it does for a particular
provider because that providers practice
is to hit the print button when she's
done with the patient and then we can
just use the print time as the checkout
time and that works like very very well
and it looks pretty nice but in a lot of
cases there's at least some left over
time after the last provider encountered
but usually it's not like egregiously
long occasionally it is somebody forgets
to check out you know all sorts of
problems to it happen but for the
provider appointments generally there is
sunlight readable checkout time
yes we were your I might have missed
this boom your data collected how long
ago well this is electron count data
from 2014 yes so I mean this might be a
non-issue but you know to include
deletion there's a certain other time
you start the patient lately or is there
certain amount of time that you expect
is that something that you can separate
from expected time no you have a certain
amount of time if you expect patients is
going to leave or wait for something but
vs is really there I mean even that
waits on itself is just on grey bar but
in the same way that you've been able to
expand and it further detail is it both
encounters at least working so bad wait
time itself is just one grey bar is
there any more information you can
gather from that way time itself I mean
if you're trying to reduce it that was
there do me like are we basically taking
into account the time the patient is
waiting while they're being dilated yeah
while I'm gonna be dilated suggested
that is it just wait time for dilation
or if and then we expect that or is that
I mean yeah we just call this red bar
this is the average time in a patient's
is waiting well at least I want the
burger for the dilation number of it
right so yeah the in the electronic
health record the staff are very good
vigilant about the swearing the time
when a patient's eyes review daily
because they really need that
information they so i put the dilator
and then they're ready so that they put
that time in their server we're not
using the timestamp when they enter the
donation time workers bulldoze is 29
that they said that they were diving now
we don't always know exactly when that
value should stop the marriage
patience we use kind of the Irish
weakness for their eyes to dilate so
that's why sometimes we have overlap
because you know that their eyes are
getting in there and we know that it
takes roughly minutes that they're
making other things going on so you
don't want to how even on dilation is
patient is correlation it's still
productive waiting I don't help it
against stuff resin judge motivator
right yes all right okay and it's the
same reason why we want to highlight
when the patient is like early before
their scheduled visit day we want to
differentiate between time that they're
waiting before they were really even
supposed to be there versus time at
their way when they're actually
scheduled to be there yes to do any kind
of observational analysis to see if kind
of related to some of these gaps if
there is activity being done related to
the patient that isn't captured in the
HR maybe a couple providers doing a
consultation the hall or something
because what you're getting that's
really not patient waiting time from the
patient's perspective it's are we
working on this patient while they're
here yeah and if so would you find I
have not been too involved with that
sort of thing one of these wonderful
people may be able to ensure get better
well Sarah and I have a drink lots and
lots observations and and so we have
seen some of the things but that we
popped up is missing data and actually
doing this work and doing more searches
this is offering recent so he's
reporting on this because it's so we're
still investigating so we are going to
active
what's going on what's being reported in
each are looking up from the HR than
what's actually in the clinic we can
actually tiny not see what the
differences are because we really do
think that like for example visual field
might have I'll just a little say
there's a minute char boat you know the
visual field takes so just but at least
we know we can get that from HR deal
that happened then you can do the
observations they operate a no okay well
I think that was a really good point and
just to follow on what Michelle was
saying that um obviously the type of
interaction that you're describing
probably cannot be captured the entire
time stamps and so I mean of course we
know that because these guys had
observed in the manually to figure out
what's really happening with my seldom
convention or PHR to what's happening
inside all I'm not sure that there's a
real way to represent that losing a big
data hey of paradigm is there only one
provider 1 10 and 11 resident know
there's usually for these charts there's
only one provider but there's often many
different texts and one of the first
sighs I showed you that you can click on
all these bars and seems logged in for
that and when you do that you do get
that representation of which tech was
where but it's kind of hard to represent
on just the picture these off with
another side of RT show which resources
just averaged across all the different
patients mmhmm yeah definitely mmm is it
normal to help the residents and fellows
not see this thing
patient it is in other words it seems to
me that I don't see residents fellows on
the same patient and I maybe mr. memory
but I actually happen I might need a new
dataset for all I know I happened to see
a scribble party nice this morn there
was like there was her and then like a
junior lurk in the room and I was
wondering if you you captured that
regularity or would it just show as her
I think that works back to the question
about there's only one exam room one
computer in an exam room is only one
person I'm denso example dr. Lola party
had a resident fellow doctor Barney
would swipe in and only heard 80 and
capture and maybe a resident which one
in later and document stuff that they'd
seen but when there's numerous flyers at
farmer whose phone was logged in their
EHR data is gonna be represented caption
i guess my last question you know you
have this data that have been next
question is now the context for that we
determine what you believe is causing
that way seven what was I said what
strategies have you thought about
birdies um yeah so I mean well basically
like thinking about different stuff and
we're actually going to go have a
meeting with a provider tomorrow to get
her I put on like what you know when she
looks at these but if she think is is
what's going on but like basically from
what I personally observed I think
there's a very noticeable effect when
the provider is had a really long exam
time in the morning and that's also
borne out by the report that was done
before I got here as well so that seems
to be a big thing like where you
schedule the exams that you know take a
long time it matters quite a bit I think
there's also probably something you said
for where you schedule dilations that
happen at the same there's it's
weird like dilations I think do
something but sometimes they sort of
staircase really nicely and everything
their time but sometimes if you have
like two dilations that are basically
happening at the same time that could be
a real problem so I think there's
definitely settle teasin how to arrange
that or and also probably some issues
with one you should be double booking
people in when you shouldn't so I think
those are the main three that have
really become clear the other thing to
try and book an actionable things right
if you look at this crystallization you
can see almost like they call the
patience or early and if not I mean some
very significant so we all know that
late patients patrona patients can a
little too so one of the questions were
trying to figure out is when do you
Morgan ever impatient so I shows up
shortly what is ok to then and not cause
other people to wait because I mean I
this is beyond the scope of this lecture
let me of something that every clinic if
Luke is reducing weight i'm not a thing
and you know there are things on here
that you know it's difficult to capture
for example miss about mythology but a
presentment primary care well I worked
in a clinic you know it wait time that
sometimes we just affected by the
complexity of a patient if I have
someone just come in from Henry feel
that takes 10 minutes right but then I
have someone who's I know to be
complicated have multiple medical issues
I can't predict no matter how good I
have they might just take up a lot of
our time that close everybody back not
anybody yeah I'm gonna use that how do
you you know so those types of trent
that they vary the more interesting
because then i can optimize in that
direction so that simple patient's you
get them in and out you have a very
efficient part of your time and then
other patients you walk out more time
and these kind of little things you know
this is a really great data i think it's
a really really interesting did a great
job what I'm really just is that next
step is now creating context for the
numbers FTF yes because that from there
you can actually kind of take steps
forward to revenge as user action bars
absolutely you know I think those are
great points is some you know Michelle's
done some really neat stuff in terms of
looking at sort of short medium versus
long patients and how can we predict
who's going to be a short verses along
patient and you know in my previous
hospital being online program very clear
mentioned he said that one department
they hadn't pitted based on whether they
said this is a no sunshine patients the
thunderstorm like I know they say you
know this patient is just going to take
up a lot of your time sad for the end of
the day or you know save them for
whatever time and just be ready for that
and that I think just data gives us that
if you can see that the provider
spending so much time with this patient
on a consistent basis and that's why I'm
again he said if this patient centered
now you have that now you know what if
each patient is because I think maybe
that would I think thank you very much
Isaac his real job I think it's really
done a nice job you know this number was
tough he's been a lot of fun a lot of
fun to you know what we were on
scheduling this Andrea and the win
basically said well is it okay to split
the time and have a faculty talk in the
second half and sociable sure and then
so she came back and said well what's
your title realize it was gonna be one
of us but huh I would happen so um what
I did is we actually thought about
having a Michelle and/or me talk about
some simulation stuff you know as a
prelude to what Isaac was doing you know
that gets into a lot of these other
topics but um you know decided that had
been pretty well covered by stuff that
Michelle is presented on healing this
forum recently as I thought what I would
do instead is talk about some stuff
involving an eye disease that I work in
called retinopathy of prematurity and
you know it's some stuff that there are
several view my students who've been
involved with this you know and now you
have two of them who you guys would know
Ryan Swan and that Aaron kleiner who's
an incoming students in September and
still rather than really focus on the
eye disease i'm hoping to zoom in on a
few take-home points which is these
concepts of science informatics and art
of medicine and how all this stuff come
together so I I'm hoping that's going to
be the generalizable point that that
people take away from this um the thing
i want to highlight and there's some
financial disclosures that aren't really
you know relevant to this stuff i'll be
presenting but um the thing i want to
highlight with this is number one that a
lot of people on you know work down the
data that i'll be showing in fact you
know mostly did these people are not me
and then you know i am actually in
charge of a consortium that includes you
know these people but the other thing is
that these people come from all sorts of
different disciplines there's some
informatics of technology computer
science engineering public health and
genetics you'll recognize them demise
people come all and ryan aaron up there
and so what I sort of take away for this
is that you know science and informatics
and research are really more and more
interdisciplinary you know than ever
before so I think that's one really neat
take-home point to this as the best eye
disease is called retinopathy of
prematurity ROP okay and that Stevie
Wonder was someone who went blind the
singer because of because of ROP and
that because one of the leading cause of
childhood blindness in the US and also
throughout the world and it's treatable
if you diagnose it early you treated
with laser or some your injections into
the eye and yeah what really happens is
that you get a retina that that part of
the eye that's developing okay so baby
just conceived the blood vessels in the
retina start growing and growing growing
and by full-term the rent should be
fully vascularized get the blood vessels
but when you get these babies who are
born prematurely get they're born at 24
weeks instead of 40 weeks you know the
vessels haven't fully developed yet and
you get these babies to get exposed to
the outside world about two-thirds of
them get a disease this disease are
and what that means that instead of
normally vascularized the retina starts
to grow up irregularly okay that's what
I propios about two thirds and premature
babies will get this and it usually goes
away by itself in about ten percent of
time it doesn't go away by itself and
you get these TV wonder lioness cases
unless they're treated he said what we
try to do is identify which are the ones
that get this which are the ones that
are likely to go bad and then treat
those babies okay and so I really want
to focus on these concepts of will call
them science informatics and art and I'm
just going to give to two examples of me
a work that we've done not just in my
career and i'll start with the
traditional teaching okay talk about
research okay that we and others have
done a kind of question that traditional
teaching and then talk about some
lessons and what the clinical impact of
that is hopefully that's going to be the
generalizable k science informatics and
art type of questions okay so long
here's example one is that we talked
about two examples I exams ok I'll
philosophy when I started practice in
2001 there was a practice guideline for
ROP that was published by the American
Academy of Pediatrics the American
Academy of Ophthalmology said that these
I exams should be done using indirect
ophthalmoscopy in the name of neonatal
intensive care unit okay so that's a
headlamp a lens and you're examining a
baby and that's the standard of care
okay for these eyes and all these papers
are hospitalized and you basically look
at the retina and draw a picture of what
you saw hand-drawn sketches and that's
pretty much even now the state of the
art so what are the challenges of this
from a practical perspective it's really
time intensive okay you have to travel
to make you coordinate with their staff
about which babies to examine you take
half a day to do a typical on some exams
the exams themselves are really
difficult they're very imprecisely
subjective and i'll talk more about that
if there's more and more babies for
surviving or small and a fewer and fewer
ophthalmologists willing to do this
because it takes too long because it's
hard because you don't get paid of a lot
of money and because there's enormous
medical legal liability actually biggish
in all about homology and
so you know really especially in rural
and other medically underserved areas
this is a huge huge problem limited
access to care and also training for
this this is used so the second aspect
of terms and challenges I want to get
into is training okay a few years ago
got interested in this issue of how well
how well are we diagnosing and
particularly on how it usually is retina
specialist in pediatric ophthalmologist
who do these eye exams and at the last
stage of medical training is what's
called a fellowship get when you stuff
specialized and how load of these
fellows perform for doing my exams and
you know why do we care how fellows
perform a number one because that's how
we build a workforce for disease and
number two because studies have shown
that about half the ophthalmologists who
do this disease are actually not even we
have a specialist or pediatric
ophthalmologist they're actually general
ophthalmologists and so in other words
they have less training than these
fellows do and so I never believed that
until I moved to Oregon and there are a
lot of general ophthalmologists who are
doing our opk organ because of that
rural bit okay so this is this is sort
of the real world and so we recruited
basically you know 12 fellows visa from
good fellowship programs in other
country and some well how well do they
perform get compared to a gold standard
of an experienced ophthalmologist panel
and you know this is their sensitivities
for diagnosing basic clinically
significant levels of disease you know
these are big whisper lioness who get
this level of disease and how they're
doing is our sensitivities of 51%
fifty-four percent thirty-six percent
thirty-two percent and so basically see
pillows are missing in a lot of cases up
to two-thirds of clinically significant
disease so basically this is a big
problem I mean we're not really doing
the job of treating this anyone will be
teaching this but alone treating it so
um you know one thing that we got
interested in years ago was can we use
telemedicine get for this purpose
you know if it's if we've got such big
problems and deliver care can we trained
nurses to take pictures of the retina
using the use a commercially available
Calvin our camera systems and then bill
attention we repositories haven't upload
the data to those repositories can make
every moment diagnosis and send
recommendations that way I'm so how will
this help well you know maybe better
quality better cost better accessibility
of care and also better objectivity so
for example this is the hand Ron sketch
this is the photo and these are actually
the same rabba on the same day and I
think that you can argue that you get a
lot more richness of data that's being
captured by the photo compared to this
sketch so um one of the first things I
did in my career was I worked on a k23
project ok Gramps because an NIH sort of
career development award and you know
those of you who are fellows now you
know may be interested in doing this and
Michelle right now is funded on okay so
if you if you have questions about that
no talk talk to her and the title of my
cave wreck was called telemedicine for
ROP diagnosis we basically built systems
evaluated their accuracy it looked the
reliability of the technology
cost-effectiveness speed you know and so
on it took six seven years in to do the
work and I think the first part of this
is can you get the correct diagnosis
using a photo compared to doing a real
eye exam and so yeah we published papers
in this other groups all those papers I
worked on a technology with you you know
of this and yeah basically turns out
that the data are pretty good okay
there's very high sensitivity for
diagnosing clinical use it against you
use and all of these studies are based
on the design where you get the gold
standard is a real eye exam and the
experiment is you take a picture of the
eye in your interpretive and what's the
sensitivity compared to that gold
standard so the short answer is that
that sensitivity is very high you know
but one of the questions we got
interested in is how do we know that the
eye exam is the gold standard in fact is
it
inherently better than taking a photo of
the retina and so on get interested in
this is this is actually not an easy
question to answer but it's really
really important in medicine especially
as we're developing all these new
technologies and the other gold standard
convenient listen to the heart using a
stethoscope or something and I know the
device can be machine the image is the
heart and so the way that we tried to
study this is looking at this question
of how well this telemedicine agree with
the real eye exam of the mosca p you
know in other words you know comparing
the two it and this is actually a hard
question to answer because there's often
variation among different doctors you
know I'll talk about this afterwards but
even when you show to people the same
data they often come up with different
diagnoses and impressions and those of
you who come from medical backgrounds
villages and so we came up with this
study design looking at intra physician
agreements between telemedicine about
the mosca p with the premise that if
it's the same observer you can
neutralize for this factor and then just
analyze the diagnostic differences that
are due solely to the modality
telemedicine or alpha velocity so we
basically collected a large data set
they had these people do the real eye
exams and then have them go back and do
telemedicine exams six months later on
the babies that they've examined
originally and compare their diagnosis
and when you do that there's eighty-six
percent intra physician agreement
between telemedicine and I'll philosophy
okay so that's pretty good but it's not
perfect and then when you go back and
look at those discrepancies okay so
eighty-six percent agreement means
fourteen percent discrepancies it turns
out in about a third of those
discrepancies the gold standard exam
showed no disease but when you look at
the photo there's actually a disease
that was missed in that white line and
there are a lot of issues in clinical
diagnosis that are very subjective he
wears the disease gaze it really close
to this optic nerve or is it far away
and that the
this is that you know with telemedicine
in principle you can make those
diagnoses if these discrepancies more
clearly because you can map it out and
draw it out and you know figure it out
on the image was when you're trying to
do this with a baby who's wiggling at
the bedside community it's often really
hard to be precise and so we felt like
in principle you actually might get a
more accurate diagnosis if you've got
the photo compared to compared to a real
exam so I thought that was interesting
and yeah we did some studies involving
if we did some studies involving you
know a cost effective business speed I'm
looking at this because it sound is
saying that the computers that we start
in 12 minutes see what happens so in
short we did some decision analysis
modeling and some time motion studies
that show that yes in fact the televised
an exam is more cost effective and it's
faster compared to the economic Catholic
exam so and I think what I took away
from this it is some some lessons in
number one within the past five ten
years there have been major real-world
programs in the US and around the world
that use telemedicine fracture diagnosis
I think that that's really neat because
it comes from the research other stuff
and you know the other thing is that the
revised american academy of
ophthalmology and pediatrics guidelines
in 2013 came up with this quote i mean i
was actually on the panel that you know
came up with this quote you know which
was carefully wordsmith and you meant to
be very big but this one says diz your
motive to Perdition is a developing
approached i will be swinging at minimum
if you do this you should comply with
the recommendations outlined here which
basically says you can do it but you
really careful okay i think and them but
to me I thought that was really really
neat because it sort of showed that you
do that you've got that need you do that
research and then you get it into policy
okay so staff it's that you know
multi-step thing and so you get
sort of close out the it actually
happens you know there's a technical
report that was put out looking at well
how do you really do this from a
workflow and implementation perspective
and so I think the lessons that I take
away from this are you know number one
how important it is to have that
multidisciplinary approach and again
that issue from going to research to
that need to the research to the
adoption policy of new technologies so
that that's example number one example
number two is what I'll call gold
standards and classification okay so it
turns out that I'm when you diagnose
this disease back in the old days the
the diagnosis of ROP was you know
completely descriptive and unstructured
okay and uh what that means that you
would basically use not found scope look
at the retina and just draw that picture
okay with no infrastructure for what the
findings really mean and in the 1980s
there was a classification system that
was developed international standard for
clinical exams okay what they did is
they bake a defined parameters and if
the parameters have to be called his own
stage clock hours and plus disease okay
and so so all of a sudden you've got the
standard terminology okay for ROP and
you know I would make them and this is
the mid-1980s and in ophthalmology in a
lot of Medicine I would argue that there
is not a lot of standardization and not
nearly as much as we probably need ok of
this sort of thing II you guys know this
from an informatics perspective and so I
think that this was a really big deal
and there have been these large-scale
sort of multicenter randomized control
trials looking at well how do you treat
disease who needs treatments how do you
treat it and yeah basically you can't
have these trials without this
infrastructure in this terminology okay
so I think that's really important it
turns out that according to these trials
the most important parameter of our own
p is what's called plus disease okay I'm
trustees is sort of a boolean variable
you either have it or you don't yes or
no and there's also pre plus that's an
intermediate state so basically yes no
or you know or borderline okay pre plus
and so if you have plus C's the baby
needs treatment basically okay and what
does plus disease me
tortuosity of the arteries and dilation
of the veins and the fat part of the
ravenna how do you know how tortuous is
tortuous how badly is dilated there's a
standard published photograph here that
was selected by experts back in nineteen
eighties so if you have this much or
more abnormality you have plus as a use
you need treatment so um so it turns out
that I was the challenge of that dog um
you know when I was starting out in
practice I saw this baby refer and the
chief complaint was I think this baby
has pluses you need to wage the baby and
I looked at that one it's really not
that dilated and tortuous a few months
later this baby comes in and the chief
complaint is so I mean this may be a
little bit nervous how can I be that far
off you know from an expert who's been
doing it for 25 years Alton Brooklyn I
was practicing new york city at the time
a few months later this baby comes in
very tortuous very dilated the chief
complaint was the opposite yeah I've
been following this baby for weeks and
I'm wondering if you think this baby
needs treatment we did a long time ago
episode if I warned you know we can't I
mean this and this can't be at opposite
ends at the same time and so we designed
that some really really simple studies
which is basically you know putting
images on the web inviting experts from
around the world to go login and enter
the diagnosis plus 3 plus or normal and
okay this one a little bit of torture
lost a little evaluation fifteen percent
plus eighty five percent a plus get this
one split fifty-fifty and there are
examples like this all over that we have
where the experts themselves don't
really agree and so this is what I want
to give in to this on science and art of
medicine um so what's plus disease you
know I once gave a talk at a conference
and there was a you know there was a
course panel and one of the other
instructors says well plus it sees like
pornography poor potter stewart a US
Supreme Court justice in the 1960s
define pornography and he says well I
can't
but I know it when I see it and so so
this buddy of mine says well plus these
like that you know it because it looks
bad I Minister if that's good yeah we
want to we want to do science and
informatics it's not good enough to see
you in hell when you see it and and what
we thought well can we capture an encode
detailed qualitative thoughts of experts
using almost like a think-aloud protocol
okay so it so we basically did this we
captured who we thought with a seven
most senior experts in the world on this
and that had them go through a bunch of
cases and we videotaped them and kind of
cognitive information while used to work
with it would build some mental models
of this and you're different examples
you know these are the exact same case
one person diagnosed at plus 1 diagnosed
pre plus 1 diagnosed normal and they're
all looking at different parts of the
retina and they're all making different
qualitative comments sort of not even
necessarily looking at the same thing
you know when you look at the different
features this is the definition our
killer tortuosity penis television but
they're all commenting on different
parts of the right now in addition to
what the definition is okay so I think
in some ways we're not really good at
articulating what we're doing and some
of this gets into the point where I'm
you know if we want to make the argument
that diagnosis is very subjective and
qualitative can we quantify it you know
using computer based image analysis and
yeah it worked with the team of people
um a lot of you know or some of you know
Jai Sri Akal patha Kramer and she used
to be a team ice and she works in boston
now and Dennis their dogmas used to work
here no it just you and moved to
Northeastern University in Boston you
know you know seven eight years ago and
Ezra was a PhD student northeast and
who's worked with together and we looked
at some questions like yo can we develop
computer-based systems to quantify these
diagnoses you know what does that
require in other words what are these
gaps in knowledge well you got a segment
of the vessels from images and then if
I'm once vessel versus background
identify which image features of a key
ones to quantify and how do you quantify
them you've got to have a reference
standard to come
air against you know people everyone
says something different how do you know
what the correct answer is you've got to
define a standard image size standard
shape you know for analysis all these
different steps and just a couple of
examples of this to come up with a
reference standard the way that we did
this a medical student Mike Ryan gave
him hey Mia talk on this a couple years
ago is that we had three different
people review the images for each eye
and you characterize it is it plus is it
pre plus or is it normal and then we had
a majority image-based diagnosis and
then you compare that with the actual
clinical diagnosis biol philosophy if
they're the same then that's the gold
standard diagnosis if they're different
that we we have a conference to sort of
resolve differences and so we looked at
all these different image features ok
which which retinal image features
correlate best with the actual clinical
gold standard diagnosis and it turns out
that of all these different these are
all previously published tensed
algorithms and the best one was
something called acceleration of the
vessel on the average which basically
means how quickly the vessel is changing
direction it's almost like the second
derivative of the position yes y
coordinate and when you do that the
performance of these systems so we've
got eight different experts and you've
got accuracy compared to that reference
standard diagnosis here that consensus
vote and the experts are between 79 and
ninety-nine percent okay we can train up
this computer system it's ninety-five
percent accurate compared to that retro
standard and if you take the consensus
of these experts especially ninety-seven
percent so overall what I take from this
is that number one experts are highly
variable and these are actually world
experts they've all published and are
considered sort of legitimate world
authorities disease and any of the
computers is doing pretty well and I
don't think this is ready for prime time
for reasons that we can talk about but
it's
not bad and now me I just want to show
basically one or two more curves we'll
finish up then yeah I thought this was a
neat curve because we've got two data
sets okay up 100 images and this one
happens to be 34 images eight experts
and red means that expert diagnosed at
image 1 to 100 s plus yellow means pre
plus green means normal okay so you see
here this expert diagnosis plus 2z is
six times more than this next group and
this is a big deal to miss call that one
or the other and the other thing is that
if you average the score for each of
these and convert to a color the
abnormality it goes along the spectrum
okay so in a way when we sort of class x
+ p + no but you're taking that
continuous spectrum of abnormality and
you're slicing it into three different
discrete categories and the point of
this is that experts differ based on
where they draw the line okay we've
actually gotten pretty good data showing
that different experts order images the
exact same but they slice differently
like this person splices it here this
person splice to hear 4 plus vs pre plus
and that's exactly how these computer
systems can help they can sort of help
us draw the line a little bit better so
on black computer may restart over here
I don't think there's a way to prevent
this I don't want to just come up with a
few lessons if we can get one of them to
do some you know this issue of computer
information Pekka I think good to me
this is done a lot to change the way
that we practice medicine you know one
piece of advice for trainees don't be
afraid to ask dumb questions I thought
that this question about yeah do people
agree with plus Aziz for me at the
beginning of my career yeah I was really
insecure about you know do I really know
what I'm doing compared to these people
and it turns out that nobody really
knows what they're doing and so you we
actually got multiple grants and sort of
build your career on something on
something that seems like kind of a dumb
question okay and so I think the weight
that would close this up would just be
on and we tried to show
examples of the science of ROP which is
like Professor creation treating disease
and to me the art is you know sort of
this stuff like yo what's pornography
was plus CDs and you know there are
subtleties that really can't be captured
by that classification system I think
that's real and you know Timmy the
informatics means a things like
telemedicine computer-based image
analysis and I guess the point that I
want to sort of leave with is that you
know good clinical care requires that
combination of all of them I think that
as intimate itions to me it's sort of
that's what our pieces sort of figuring
out how to mix that informatics with
that science where that armed okay so
thank you very much yeah um so first
question happens so you mentioned that
that Tom medicine was cheaper more cost
effective what was the reason for the
increased cost for manual optimist I'm
just curious what was the reason for the
increase in cost because on surface it
sounds like it would be cheaper is their
local them yeah no scope so what exactly
were the cost how does costume yeah the
way that we live and that's actually
that's a good question of the way that
we modeled this was based on sort of the
cost of the cost of telemedicine being
young how much do you charge for a
television exam and it turns out they're
actually significantly cheaper to do
then Thomas gothic exams I think that's
the single biggest cost savings when we
did this modeling we didn't moderate to
include things like you know how much
does it cost to buy your machine
whatever and but then so that's a little
bit that's a little bit more complicated
but um you know the numbers um you know
well that it was about forty percent
more cost effective you know based on
Strictly sort of a Medicare
reimbursement model and then my other
question is in terms of I know this is
difficult because
to dispel like kind of creating a gold
standard but you know with the diagnosis
then the next step is does the fact of
using columnist it does that lead to
better outcomes preventing following
this so that my second question is has
that been shown that as good or better
outcomes yeah that's have that's a great
question it's really tough to its really
tough to answer you know I think that
it's I don't foresee that there's ever
going to be a trial that looks at
outcomes because it would just takes too
long to end up doing with the incidences
of these you know diseases and you know
what we do know is that outcomes from
n.y quite honestly with alpha mosca p
you know we never know really why babies
are going blind when they're going blind
you know is it because they were meant
to go blind or was it because they
weren't getting screening or they got
lost to follow-up or is it because the
person who did the eye exam miss call
bit and then you let something go and
your luck in those examples up there and
so on so I think that those are really
really tough in the real world to to get
to the bottom of you know what we do
know is in the operational telemedicine
systems out there they've actually had
very good outcomes and so I think that's
a really it's a really tough question to
answer but my guess is that that's going
to be that's going to be the best but
anybody can ever do with them yeah hey
so first year that you would live even
though you're giving Levy's 390 hit rate
with your with your system which is
quite wicked one percent less than the
world yeah sure it was ninety-five
percent accuracy of vs ninety-seven
percent so you said you don't think it's
ready for prime time in certain other
areas that would be considered really
nice yeah what are some of the reasons
you think it's all right yeah let me let
me tell you why I'm like one of them the
biggest one is that the system that we
use here deals require manual
segmentation of the images in other
words the computer system wasn't that a
it picked up a lot of garbage when it
was doing automated segmentation and it
happens that if we do a purely automated
segmentation system the performance is
actually pretty good also but it's just
not ninety-five percent the other
requests that i think that's reason
number one you know of course we can
come up with a system where you help if
I you know refining it which we don't
have yet the second thing is that i'm
not sure that we fully characterized
exactly what are the best parameters you
know to look at now maybe if we can get
ninety-five percent and there are world
experts who are getting seventy-nine
percent maybe doesn't really matter you
know in that case but but i do think we
want to do a little bit of extra work
i'm at walmart maybe only use it to
screen for the green cases essentially
something that the expert doesn't need
to look at because it's so likely to be
yeah it's funny that we've been trying
to do that exact project right now look
at how would we draw the how good is
that using a bigger data set compared
this was a hundred images using a bigger
data set and so i think that that's
exactly long the lines of what we're
trying to do right now and then cause
all the edge pieces i exactly obvious
ones to an expert yeah exactly yeah so I
what I was wondering is both about the
current practice with apologists and are
they in routine practice at this point
of taking images when they do exams and
not why not and then the second thing
being sort like do you have a lot of
issues with inter photographer variation
like the quality of an image is probably
going to
remotely or a computer algorithm
interpreted so is that a difficult
situation yeah those are those are great
questions um in terms of the first one
which is do we take photos routinely you
know we do at ohsu yeah but one of the
reasons we take them routinely is that
we do a lot of teaching and we do a lot
of research and so we take photos for
that reason in the real world i think
that most nick hughes have a camera and
most people are not routinely taking
photos along with the eye exam and it's
probably because of time constraints and
you know just takes twice as long to do
the photo and also to take your photo to
do the exam and also take a picture of
it in the real world you know isaac was
talking about these I exams and you know
when you go to the office a lot of times
people do get photos taken and I think
probably the reason for that is that
it's not the doctor that's taking a
photo and it doesn't interfere with a
doctor's workflow it makes a patient
wait longer but you know you just get to
the doctor 30 minutes after you
otherwise would have but but so I think
that that's that's sort of the first
answer the photo part the second part is
the quality of the image um yeah I
definitely think that it matters who
takes it and I don't think we have great
standards for training and you know in a
lot of ways you know I think that you
could argue that it doesn't matter who
your surgeon is or who which way the
ology tech took your photo um I think
that all of us who do medicine know that
it does matter but it's not always that
easy to get to you know which how do you
know whether it's good or bad you know
how do you you know standardized that
stuff um and so one of the Nevsky it's
interesting Aaron coiner who's the
incoming game ice one of the incoming
PhD students has been working on a
rotation whether to of the Sun worries
looking at some algorithms for assessing
image quality where the idea is they
would do something similar you know
these every would filter out this image
is good enough
not good enough for processing and you
will see what that goes because I'm I
think that's going to get a little bit
to what what you're asking about great
look guys stay thank you very much